端法ヌードル
めちゃくちゃ可愛いありがとうございますはいみなさん2018年になったわけなん
ですけども
去年の僕のテーマ
皆さん覚えてますか ok
ラーメンを禁止していました去年の1月の12日から禁止しますって言ってたんで今年
の1月12日まで5を食べない予定です
岸壁に空港れ2017年1本目箱
去年ラーメン屋さんで棒組と人間は一人もいないでしょまあ正直なカード結構食べたく
なるっていう欲求がたまにはあったんですけどそこまできつくなかったです何か別の
例えばハンバーガーとかぎゅうどうとかって結構代用できたしなかなか苦しい局面で
あったんですけども意外といけたのではないかなと思っておりますあと1週間ぐらい
ちょっと食べないように頑張りますそこでなんですけども今までの北乃きい
親子の歴史をちょっとたとっていきましょう2016年に奥華子を禁止しましたこれが
すごいつながったのを覚えています実際お菓子食べないとなんかおかしくなっつんとも
あったんで
ジュース戻れないわけでしょ結構もメンタル的に不可能だなって思って厳しい1年に
なりました
どうぞ2017年を科すようになった僕はなーめんに目覚めてしまいアホほどラーメン
食った結果
が2017年にな命を近似することになって縁もラーメン記事が終わるのところで
ございますさあ
2018年
僕は何を禁止すればいいのでしょうか朝敵なんか掲示しなくてもいいんじゃねとか思っ
ちゃうんですけど
なんか
禁止するのが楽しくでさ記述するのは楽しく県なくてがついたわけでもないんですけど
意外とね剣士することによって何か見える何かっていうのがあるんですよ僕は冒せを
禁止してお菓子のあることの素晴らしさ幸せたを吸ってラーメンを禁止してラーメン
以外においしいものがたくさんある鉄砲改めて確認できて立つに何かを禁止しようと
思ったときに僕な日すればいいのかなと思う
たんですけどローグが気づいてしまったんです縛られるということの喜びを
そういうわけじゃないんですけど何かを我慢することによって得られるないかっていう
ものが僕あるって言うことはもう気づいているんで
今年も何かを検証と思ってるわけなんですけれども今回
てが今年は僕がその今年休止するものを
[音楽]
皆様に決めてもらおうと思いますというわけでみなさん僕が今年剣士すべきものを
コメントで書いてくださいで一つはされちゃいけないことが僕はなぜ継承するかって
いう理由ですねお菓子にしろラーメンする強調していることは僕が太らないようにする
ため
あと健康的な意味を込めて禁止していました k 出漁なご飯でお願いしますご飯ご飯
系
コメント多分どこかで動画で紹介すると思うのでそこはご了承ください
条件で何かご飯じゃなくても別に好きなものを買っちゃってくださいまあそれで僕が
今年禁止すべきものを書いてくれるとありがたいです
それでなんか good の数とか見て僕が判断して今年なに贈っするか決めようと
思いますとりあえず皆さんに僕が何を記述べきかを
決めてください
[音楽]
ドキドキしてきちゃっとりあえず本当に僕はラーメンが楽しみですあと1週間でくると
思うのでそれまで
いきます1月10日ぐらいまで書いてくれればまあ見方になって感じです皆さんこれと
よろしくお願いしますじゃあ
[音楽]